الى اجراء اي تغييرات في السلطه القضائيه
من شانها ان تمنح حكومته نفوذا اكبر في
اختيار القضاه وتحد من سلطه المحكمه
العليا في الغاء التشريعات هذه الخطه
اثارت تظاهرات ومواجهات استمرت لاسابيع
حيث وصف معارضها نتنياهو بانه يحاول تقويض
استقلال المحاكم لكن مع تراجع نتنياهما
ابرز هذه التعديلات يظهر مشروع القانون
المعدل انه لا يمكن تعيين اكثر من قاضيين
في المحكمه العليا خلال تصويت اعتيادي في
جلسه واحده بالكنيست كما يتعين اقرار اي
تعينات تتجاوز ذلك موافقه اغلبيه الاصوات
بما في ذلك قاض واحد على الاقل ونائب
معارض واحد من اعضاء لجنه الاختيار
التعديلات الجديده التي تم ادخالها تشير
الى انه سيتم توسيع لجنه الاختيار من تسعه
الى 11 عضوا كما هو مقترح في الاصل لكن مع
تركيبه تمنح الحكومه نفوذا اقل المشروع
الم عدل ايضا استخدم لغه اكثر تحافظا
مقارنه بتلك الوارده في مشروع القانون
الاصلي لكن ما تزال سلطه القضاء في لجنه
الاختيار محل جدل خاصه فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه استخدام معتبر حق النقد تلقائي
على الترشيحات لمنصه القضاء
وفي خطوه يبدو انها تصعديه اعلنت المعارضه
في اسرائيل انها ستقدم طعنا امام المحكمه
العليا ضد مشروع القانون المقدم من
نتنياهو لتعديل قواعد تعيين القضاه فقال
زعيم المعارضه انه سيقدم الطعن في اللحظه
التي سيتم فيها تمرير التعديلات على لجنه
التعيينات القضائيه وتشهد اسرائيل
احتجاجات كبيره ضد قانون تغيير النظام
القضائي